first of all
let's just imagine that we've got 10
tracks of our brain
okay you know that our brain can do 10
things at one time
one of those tracks if you're a writer
should be
always sensitive to and aware of
ideas they're out there they're out
there all over the place
they're in newspaper articles they're in
conversations you hear with people at
the coffee shop
they're on the radio they're on click
your click click click
click thing that happens i know for
example
i know david rabinowitz and charlie
wachtel
who wrote black klansmen and i
interviewed them and i said well how did
you guys come up with it and
i think david said well i was trying to
avoid writing
and so i was just doing a click click
click thing and i stumbled on this
facebook article about this guy ron
stallworth who was the first black
policeman in colorado springs who then
did this thing with the kicks clan
so that's how they discovered it so one
thing is just be
conscious of it the other thing is be
intentional
you know like every day
you should be thinking about story ideas
now people are not going to necessarily
you know it's going to vary from person
to person but there have been times in
my life where i literally
said i'm going to come up with an idea a
day every day
i'm going to come up and it's and a
third point to that
related is dr linus pauling who's the
only person to win two nobel prizes
and he has that saying the best way to
come up with a good idea is to come up
with a lot of ideas
and so that's a third point that you can
do is just generate a lot of ideas
keep a file like i've got a word file
stretching back 20 some odd years with
literally hundreds and hundreds of ideas
most of them awful but you
keep working that muscle and then
eventually
i think chances are that you're going to
surface something
now then you have to assess the ideas
and so there's certain questions you can
ask like well
is this big enough to be a movie you
know who's the audience for this
um what's the hook you know that central
conceit
like when i sold k9 you know um
i remember going into an executive's
office
and they said what you guys did was so
brilliant
you took the buddy action comedy formula
the police cop and you put in rent 1010
who was like the biggest star in
hollywood back in the late 20s and 30s
and i learned a very valuable lesson
there which is that you always when
somebody gives you a compliment
even if you didn't mean it you go yeah
that's exactly what i was thinking so i
said yeah that's exactly what we were
thinking
because i hadn't thought that at all but
um you know
you that idea i could walk in at that
point in time in 1987
i could have walked into any producer's
office or any bar where people were
hanging out
what are you working on i said yeah i
got this idea k9
loner cop new partner police dog
they would see that so the hook there is
the police dog
nobody had done that you know so you
look for like
inception the idea of being able to go
inside someone's groundhog day we're
living this
that thing what's that thing that's
going to set it off from
you know something else so those are
some key you know
have one part of your brain going be
intentional about it um
you know be generating a lot of ideas
and hoping that you'll come up with you
know
some really good ones some strong ones
off that and then assess them to make
sure that you feel like it's big enough
and good enough to be a movie
my first step in writing a screenplay is
coming up basically coming up with a
hundred ideas and picking the best idea
um i have a thing called the hundred
idea theory that doesn't necessarily
doesn't have to be a hundred ideas but
if i come up with one idea
that's one idea and it could be a
terrible idea if i come up with 100
ideas or
60 ideas or whatever i can comb through
and find the very best idea
and then i take it to thunderdome
i take that idea and i go
i write the script to this everyone's
going to say is going to pick it apart
so i want to pick it apart first i want
to find all the flaws with whatever
ideas
the idea is and try to get past those
flaws
and and remove them so that the idea is
great
that is actually the bane of the
writer's existence especially the
screenwriter
to come up with something new i mean
when you think about
um i think in in the the second edition
of the 101 habits bill marseille one of
the one of the screenwriters there talks
about doing the 20s
uh so for him like everything that he
thinks about any event
uh any scene character whatever he
thinks of kind of listing 20
different ways of doing it like if it's
like a you know
talk about the meat cue to writing
romantic comedy how people meet
in a cute way well he's going to do 20
different thoughts about it okay they
can be this
i mean you have to do he does 20 because
the
the first two or three or five of them
will be cliches
will be things that you know you're
automatically going to think about them
because
they're the most famous ones they're the
ones that we've seen a hundred times
but by going deeper and he forces
himself to go deeper
that's where you get the creativity and
the originality and eventually
when you reach that past the 10 or 12 15
although up to 20 you'll start getting
some really original
ways because you forced yourself and so
that's that's what the writer needs to
do
you got to force yourself to go deeper
in order to create some original writing
do the 20 for anything you know 20
different ways to rob a bank
20 different ways to uh to say i love
you
20 different ways to break up with
someone 20 different ways to
kill someone i mean there's all these
things that you've seen 100 times and
when you see it over and over you go
you know you go huh you know because
you've seen it 100 times
and it's only the really the movies that
break out stories the stories that break
out the ones that are kind of truly
original
right
to me where it starts is a really
compelling problem
that is going to take the whole story to
be solved that
millions of strangers consuming that
story would be able to identify with
this problem and care
that it gets solved and be really
entertained by the process of watching
people try to solve it so that's kind of
a lot of things in one but to me that's
kind of where it all starts with
there's something that someone's going
through in life
that really matters to them and
hopefully to us as the audience it's
really important it's really difficult
it's going to take a lot of effort and
active
action toward trying to solve it which
isn't going to work
so it's difficult it's complicated
trying to solve it usually leads to push
back
and complications and things that don't
go as planned and so that tends to build
the sense of
problematic situation so it's growing
and escalating
building over the course of the story
and then in the end there's some kind of
resolution
that has taken the audience on a journey
and usually taken
certain characters on a journey where
they're not the same
as what they were and therefore it was
meaningful and important in some way
that they went through that
there's certainly the wow factor of
that's the most amazing thing i've ever
heard and well i have to have that
i have to have that right now how do i
get that story how do i get that book or
magazine or a true life story
um when i when i heard the story of
christine palisac
being a fact checker at 23 years old and
working at
la weekly and breaking the grim sleeper
uh serial killer in los angeles
i i didn't need to know anymore but then
there's stories that will
i just can't let go i'll go back to and
go back to him but it was the
the hopefully the next movie i'm going
to make
uh in the amazon was a story that i
chased for five years
and uh it was a true life story and i
just couldn't let it go
and some other producer got it and uh
failed at developing it and i would call
every six months and
after about a year and a half they
abandoned the other producer
and went with me and it really i just
could not let it go it was a story i had
to tell
one way or the other i was going to tell
that story that's the true story of
julianne kepcke who
in 1972 was living
in peru going to the american school she
was 18
was in her senior year her parents were
noted zoologists she had lived part of
her childhood in the
amazon her parents were cataloging
butterflies and bats
and then when she got to middle school
they moved her to lima and she grew up
there spoke
perfect german perfect english perfect
spanish
and uh because it was uh
they're on a different schedule than us
because their seasons are different than
us
uh their school year ends in december
so she was both graduating and going to
her prom
in december and her dad wanted them to
go
to the amazon on christmas
eve and she wanted to stay and so
he went early and she and her mom stayed
behind in lima and she
went to her prom graduated with her
friends and then they got on a plane
and when the plane was over the amazon
it was hit by lightning twice
and disintegrated in midair and she was
in the window seat still strapped in
and as she said the i didn't leave the
plane the plane left me and she found
herself
uh at 15 000 feet in her chair upside
down
pinwheeling and uh she
fell blacked out fell hit the canopy of
the amazon which broke her fall
it's a miracle perhaps she's the longest
free fall without a parachute
and the canopy broker fall and she
landed in the amazon woke up had nothing
but a broken collarbone that she knew of
she had one shoe lost her glasses and
for the next
nine days followed the river and the
lessons that she learned from her father
and her own desire not to die
and was rescued and she's a friend of
mine now she's now in her 50s
and she's an extraordinary woman she
spends half her year in munich
and the other half of the amazons trying
to save the rainforest
and uh we're gonna go down to bogota
and uh and and the amazon and hopefully
tell that story at the beginning next
year
i think for me our movie really begins
uh with an idea
or the story the key story element or
or the what if like this is kind of like
a fall
and sometimes like uh low will bring you
know will have an idea or have a dream
uh and say oh this is really great and
you're like i always jot it down
like i jot down her ideas and and her
dreams and my dreams
when i have an idea or a thought i wake
up from or if i'm daydreaming and
and like oh you know so i kind of try to
write all those little thoughts down and
then eventually
what i find happens is there's some of
those ones that get written down there's
one that kind of keeps
chirping keep like hey and like it like
more ideas
come to it and at a certain point it
reaches critical mass i mean usually
when i have like
10 or 12 pages of ideas relating to a
particular story it kind of reaches the
critical mass where i start going okay
now we're gonna figure out the you know
what this is is a real script
you know all these ideas are great and
then figuring out what coalesces into
the script
and then it kind of evolves like i work
with low like
ever you know when i finish the first
draft is very useful because she usually
gets fresh eyes on it at that point
so it's great to get like a fresh
perspective and then the story grows and
then of course
as you are inspired by locations or
or real things you experience and
oftentimes when you as it
progresses like when you start casting
like an
actor can be a huge like influence in
terms of
like oh this person is like changes that
character this could make the movie turn
into this
so all those things kind of and it just
kind of grows so it's fun
it's my probably my favorite part
a lot of them just stem from
stories that i would love to see
as a as a filmmaker that i would love to
go to the movies and watch
and you know a lot of them comes from
movies that i've watched over and over
and over again or
or you know a lot of the inspiration
comes from from movies in general
you know you watch a scene and you think
to yourself oh you know what well that
would be really interesting to
even even a line of dialogue that the
character could say you know you take
that and go you know
that that in itself could be a story
like that's something would be
interesting to explore so
we just try and find things that that we
would love to see as as filmmakers and
writers
and and stories that we would we would
love to to
to be told you know you know there's
actually a really
interesting old canadian movie
i say old it was about the late 90s and
it was called when good ghouls go bad
and it stars christopher lloyd who is
one of the most
amazing actors it's a it's you know
everybody knows him as doc brown and
back to the future but a lot of his
stuff
his serious work and his comedic work is
is just
fantastic so but he has a he has a line
where he's speaking to
his son and his son basically says you
know you used to be
this go-getter you used to be you know
and the town is dealing with the death
of this kid who
he got stuck in this like kiln overnight
and the dad and so the the town sort of
deals with that heavy weight
and the dad basically says you used to
be happy you used to be
um a go-getter you used to build things
and make things and
and help people and the and christopher
lloyd says yeah and i built the kiln
that that kid died in
and it's one of those moments in that
movie where you know you don't need he
didn't need to say that that didn't need
to be a part of the movie but it was
and that right there you look you go oh
man like that in and of itself dealing
with
the trauma of of
of doing something you love and then
that thing you love kills somebody
you know that in of itself could be an
incredible story so yeah there's a lot
of a lot of things in movies and i i try
my best to write them down when i
when i feel them and i see them and i
hear them but that would that would
definitely be a an example of something
that has all that has inspired me
you want to come up with an idea for a
story um but you don't really know where
to start so one good place to start that
i have in my book is
the comp game so for those who don't
know what a comp is a comp
is this meets that you know so like a
movie is
harry meets sally meets air bud
what is that movie gonna be so there's
your assignment you come up with and
this is a
um since my fiance's sitting here i'll
tell this story
okay uh so a script i have out uh that
i'm passing on is called run
uh it is a story about a detective who
is being forced to
run non-stop uh in order to save her
daughter from a killer
um it's placed in several contests
at this point i've been semi-finalist uh
in
in like three of them and
quarterfinalists another two um and it's
a script that like a lot of people seem
to like um
where did that story come from okay so
we were playing the comp game one day
driving to a networking event stuck in
traffic
so we were playing a cop game coming up
with i was coming with
bizarre things she was kind of bizarre
things i think at one point i told her
she needed to do
i might have actually said airbud meets
something else so she gave me okay
saw meets speed okay
so i'm like okay so speed is you know
the dude in the
bus that can't slow down or it's going
to blow up saw is this
killer guy who has these people and
making them do obstacles to save their
own lives
so i mesh them together i now have a
woman who can't stop running or her
daughter will die and she has to
along with running has to do these
various like
uh feats that he makes her do and stuff
like oh she has to run
to this point in this amount of time and
go if you don't then your daughter's
friend who i also have kidnapped is
gonna die
so i'm combining those two things so
there's your homework
let's give you a like a couple of uh
comps or whatever to come up with so
okay
so how about
16 candles meets home alone okay 16
candles in the home alone
so we're going to take those two movies
we're gonna merge together 16 candles
you got
a story about a girl who it's her
birthday and everyone seems to have
forgotten that it's her birthday
uh home alone is a guy who his parents
go on vacation and leave him there
awesome all right so
we got kids home alone it's his birthday
all right so we've got
kid's birthday uh he wakes up nobody
remembers his birthday he goes off
he comes home to a house that is full of
stuff for a surprise party but everyone
else is gone they set up and they left
him alone
so while he's at the surprise party
waiting around his own party
uh some people try to break into his
house luckily he's got things
already around now that he can use to
defend himself he has a banner that he
turns into a giant slingshot to shoot
the
bad guys across the street uh they come
in oh look here's birthday cake with
with uh trick candles on it so he lights
the trick candles now he's got
roman candle torch that he can use as
defense and shoot it off like a big
firework of people uh
and then the parents once he's defeated
the bad guys they come home everybody
comes home
forgetting that they set up for this
birthday party don't know
why there's all this mess here until the
mom finds the uh the banner at the end
and then
oh by the way your birthday present
happens to be something he destroyed
while trying to do it
idea outside my head it probably sucks i
know it sucks but
there that's kind of what the comp game
is you come up with things they may not
be good
they may be amazing it's kind of a thing
of trying to figure out how to
meld the two things together because
there is i'm a firm believer that there
are no more original stories left to
tell
because we've been telling stories since
the dawn of time
the trick is to find new ways into the
stories
and the reason i have the comp game is a
fantastic way of doing that is taking
two stories that already exist and
finding where they meet in the middle
what is it the venn diagram where
they've got the circles and things over
here so
finding those things is a great way to
to create your own story by melding
other stories already existing i'm just
going to be don't be super
obvious about it like i just was with
this 16 candles home alone
um like i said with the run i knew it
had to be something
that couldn't stop moving from speed and
there had to be a serial killer
with obstacles like saw and so i created
a whole new character that went into
there
uh and how to mesh them together like
she's no longer on a bus now she's
running you know so find
the the original idea in them um
another thing you can do is coming up
finding
a movie you like but that has [ __ ]
ending
can i say [ __ ] i'm sorry i have a crappy
and uh tweak it to okay
how would you have ended this story can
you now write a story that ends that way
and has a different beginning
you know so so you can always borrow
from other things like um
even in people borrowing even even uh
william shakespeare was borrowing people
you know
romeo and juliet was not an original
thing he stole romeo and juliet from
like a greek mythology thing and then
just
made his own tweaks to it you know so we
can make our own tweaks to everything so
your homework
is to find a story that already exists
find a way to spin it and make it a
completely new original story
okay argo and sleeping with the enemy
oh crap can we just cut i don't want to
do that anymore oh jeez
we could end it there okay sorry i just
wanted to
throw out that one okay now
[Laughter]
so somebody got kidnapped
and it was it turns out that it was his
lover
but in order in order to save his lover
he has to make a movie that involves his
lover
[Laughter]
this actually sounds like a good one
okay
this is a fun game so it should be a
party game yeah you should i can see
michael's craft
there is a similar party game oh we have
it what's it called
uh pitch storm is similar that one it
doesn't do it doesn't do quite the same
thing it doesn't take movies and make
you combine them
pitch storm is uh it's a card game where
in each
on the cards they have different
elements like
a certain type of character and a
certain scenario
and you have to come up with the story
that uses that and you're
pitching it and then um it has kind of
like a an apples-to-apples
component so there's a judge and the
judge is actually throwing out
things too they're actually being the
executive you know and so while you're
telling the story
at any point they can stop you like oh
but what if and then they have an
executive card that has like some random
thing that they throw in there some note
that they're like oh what if
you know you're so i'm telling my story
of ron you know the the woman who's
let's say my thing was a detective and
and running and so like i'm telling the
story
okay so she's running and the detect or
the bad guy calls her and tells her she
has to get to this certain point
and he goes oh let me stop you what if
suddenly
aliens drop down so you know it's a
bizarre little game like that it's a
similar concept
specifically all roads to perla is set
in texas
uh it's it was more of my ode to
my time there and the things that i was
uh
experiencing on the road as a traveling
photographer of different assignments i
i would get all these
i would meet all these people with all
these faces and i didn't want that to
end
one assignment that really had an impact
was sex trafficking in
houston and uh that left
a pretty big imprint on me and
and uh i went down there they were like
hey man
can you do this assignments it's uh down
near
houston and harris county there's 80
about 80 massage parlors
in a two mile radius and then um
but they're illegal they're brothels and
things like that so i
i would then next four four five days
later i found myself
in a parking lot sitting in a sheriff's
car about to go in a raid
and we get on and and we we get in
and just what i experienced you know
it's like the underbelly of
life in the world it was just um
pretty interesting you know and then i
had other signs about like exoneries
so i was always drawn to human interest
stories stories that
were really um maybe
you know they're not happy but it's
happening
you know since that's out there um and
that's what gets me uh gets me kind of
intrigued
because of these you know we
we all can't be um
you know living such a privileged life
everyone's got their own struggles so i
i was able to see that
and my duty was at the time to visually
capture that
and then but i wanted to write about
write stories about
people who are who are um flawed
you know that's i guess everyone does
that but but
specifically at the time texas you know
it
it it really seeped into the
storytelling because i was on the road
there a lot
that's i think what also uh charles
bukowski talked about just like
he had worked so many of these odd jobs
and he felt that the
stories of the working class really
seeped into all of his writing because
that's who he was around
yeah absolutely i mean like that's why
we're talking forward well how do you
get back
you live you know i was out of school
like i was
22 and and i was writing at the american
bankers association
in washington c at washington dc about
banking news i did it for three years
moved to new york to try and play music
moved to new york and never played music
again because i was 25 at that time
because i found the camera and i got
obsessed with the camera
and then uh you know i worked as a
floral assistant a
busboy delivery person anything
and once i told my mom i wasn't
going to uh uh
i'm actually applying for a busboy
position she was like
what oh my goodness what are you doing
she was like i was like
i just need a change you know and then
um
and that and that led me to waiting
tables you meet so many different people
i let then you know just all different
types of jobs i would try to do
um and then and that's how that's how
you get stories that's because you loved
it you see it you see interesting folks
you know and then it's much better then
you kick in the daydreaming and then you
have some sort of
uh idea of what it is in that type of
world you know
like i still remember being in that
parlor
and seeing what you know the the women
that were just trapped there and these
guys and
all it smells like lotion and you know
these things
it's just stick with you you know i'm
very visual
but the sensory of smell and place and
these confines
and then you're in a prison or you're
doing other things there's
there's life is life is definitely
interesting you know and i think that's
why i was you know trying to explore
with the stories i
i want to tell
i have a sounding board who is
i guess he's kind of my secret weapon
but he's he's someone who's
you know he's seen he's seen all my
short films and he's always the first
person i go to
with with an idea like even a treatment
stage to be like is this any good or is
this like really terrible and if it is
really terrible can i salvage it
you know is there a way to make it
better and it's um it's a very good
friend
called faisal a qureshi and he's a
professional screenwriter
and he's based in the uk he's also
directed uh
films and he i think it's very important
as a writer to be able to show
someone that you trust something that
you're not entirely sure if it's any
good or not
because he no he knows me well enough
now that he knows that he can be really
harsh and it's okay because at the end
of the day i just want to know if i'm
wasting my time or not
um and he has been very harsh and i
really appreciate it
um because i have had instances where
it's like i've sent him a treatment
and he'll tell me what's wrong with it
like in a very kind of brutal way but
then that's good because it helps me
figure out how i can make it
better and i have actually been able to
like make it better and like get onto
fellowships with treatments that before
he was like
i don't think so yeah and do you does he
reciprocate in terms of he sends you his
scripts
he does yeah he has sent me his
materials
uh before so definitely i think that
that's so
important is to have someone because i
think definitely i always feel like in
this
industry you only really get like one
chance to like impress people
so you want to send them you want to put
your best foot forward
and that's why it's important to have
someone who whose opinion you trust
and whose craft you you really admire
and you recognize that they're really
talented and they're really intelligent
and you can just show them like your
worst stuff
and they will you know give you
suggestions um
and will tell you maybe what you could
do to make it a little bit better
does he ever ask you to be more harsh
does he
oh yeah yeah like just just tell me like
i don't like
did he have to encourage or because i
could see you not wanting to hurt
someone's feelings
absolutely very much so and
and yet he's like you know like you're
like just be honest like please
just like tell me because i do i do
always think like i don't want to hurt
anybody's feelings
yeah right yeah i think that'd be really
important to have a a
you know working relationship or just a
friendship with someone where you could
give them
and you know that they're not trying to
wound you to stop you but they're just
trying to
help make you better and i think that's
a rare thing to find absolutely
so that's why you know big shout out to
to faisal nice and i think someone who
kind of
you know because they they've read your
previous work and they've seen like your
previous films that they kind of
they they know what you're trying to do
and
and because of that they can tell you i
know i think i know what you're trying
to do but you're maybe you're not doing
it
the best way that you could do it so let
me just you know ask you some questions
and
and you know make some suggestions
because i think i know where you're
trying to get
i think that's very important because i
mean there are some people who you just
don't understand your work and don't
understand your films
and you know don't want to and maybe not
the best people
to get feedback from how do you know
personally
when your movie idea isn't working not
not so much if you've given it to
someone as a sounding board but
personally
i think that it's when you
you yourself are writing it and you are
not excited by what you're writing
i think that i think you know that it's
working when you're like
you know i really want to keep you know
i want to keep going i want to know i
personally want to know what happens
next
but if you're kind of like trudging
through it and you're like oh
god i have to write another five pages
or i have to write you know another
another
you know five five like you know five
paragraphs of this treatment if you
yourself are having that thought
trust me whoever is reading it is gonna
also have
the same thought of oh god i have to
read another five pages before this is
over
yeah have you ever abandoned an idea
like you've been excited about it for a
little while and then realized your
heart wasn't in it
i think yeah definitely but i think more
with like um i mean i have had that with
a feature script yeah which i was like
ah this is not working as a feature but
i managed to kind of recycle it
into something else um
and then also short films like you know
if you if you've you know written a
short film script that was a
collaboration with with
a friend and then you apply to a lot of
funding and you just keep getting
rejected and then it's like okay well
then let's just not
so the universe was telling you
something or at least you took it that
way
and then you just move on to the next
project because that got funding okay
well then i'll just do that
you